we'll go back to your first feature
while then blue you had done two shorts
previously where did you get the
confidence to know that you could write
it and then execute on it I just I saw
it like I loved confidence is really
what you have I mean you have confidence
as a filmmaker for sure but it's more
like I just had a vision of what I
wanted the movie to feel like and sound
like and the characters to say and if I
was able to articulate that then I felt
confident in my abilities so I just
think it came through doing it for me
and it's also like you know you as a
filmmaker you have to own what you do
right so if you if you own your words
and you own the material that you're
making and you own like you own up to it
right then I think that with that comes
confidence right so you're willing to
take the risks and make the movie that
you want to make it's scary but it's you
have to be the cop to have confidence
and everything to do that where do you
go for screenwriting guidance do you go
to a book do you go to a website I mean
I I've read save the cat I read other
books and I read a lot of screenplays
you know I've think I've read
taxi-driver screenplay like probably 15
times 20 times she just just reads
screenplays same way that like you watch
movies to see how movies are done you
you know you read screenplays you know
I've broken down I had a class in
college that all you did was he's you
broke down you watched your favorite
movies you watch like Hitchcock's films
and he broke down each act and each
structure and you broke down the script
and how it corresponds to the movie in
the movie to your script and so you just
keep breaking him down you want to see
how they shot the scene how they covered
it you watch the movie you pause it look
at it look at the shot why did the shot
go from a dolly to a why and why did the
WYD go to the close-up here and why is
it a down angle point it up you know and
why do the shots exist with they do on
screen you know just look at it that was
my education
as it has watched my favorite films
you